[Musique]
bonjour ma vie chez jean king bonjour
nous visualisons manger aux auditeurs
directrice de l'agencé margerie qui
édite veille tourisme dentiste une revue
qui s'intéresse plus particulièrement à
l'économie du tourisme dans nos régions
cette agence existe officiellement
depuis un an à peu près m'a dit janine
king top resa vient de fermer ses portes
cette grand-messe du tourisme mondial
sans annonce particulière pour nous
faut-il croire au tourisme en martinique
il espère bien j'espère parce que le
tourisme c'est un secteur qui est
capable de générer des emplois qui est
capable de générer des emplois qualifiés
sur site c'est un secteur qui est
capable de générer des devises des
recettes touristiques
donc même s'il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
particulière à te prisa et en même temps
tant mieux parce qu on est tellement
habitué aux effets d'annoncé que quand
il y en a pas je vais peut-être s'en
réjouir on l'y voit seulement habitué
aux effets d'annoncé oui totalement
installé à caen
la martinique a cette fâcheuse habitude
d'annoncer des choses et puis un an plus
tard deux mois plus tard cinq ans plus
tard on ne voit rien se produire et ça
du coup ça décrédibilise ont manqué de
consistance
oui suffit de voir le tcsp bien d'autres
domaines vous accusez qui par exemple
ceux qui décident de la politique
touristique de nos pays
non je ne suis pas là pour accuser ge a
dit juste souhaite dès lors on fait une
annonce ça veut dire qu'on crée de la
tente et donc il faut suivre ça et
ensuite générer des actions et ensuite
générer des résultats dont le tourisme
du frustré on est aigri pensée qui n'est
partie du quai par exemple qui attend de
la manne financière de ce secteur
d'activité et je pense qu'ils en
bénéficient quand même c'est à dire que
le tourisme génère des millions d'euros
peut-être que ça pourrait générer plus
peut être que les retombées pour être
mieux à distribuer mais il ya des
personnes qui vivent du tourisme les
personnes qui travaillent en en hôtel
par exemple ou un restaurant elle en
vivent
est ce qu'elles sont frustrés ça je sais
pas je l'avais pas poser des questions
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que le
tourisme de manière générale en
martinique beaucoup de personnes s'y
intéresse c'est un sujet transversal et
c'est un sujet qui est très souvent dans
les foyers tout le monde a un avis sur
le sujet mais quelle est la réalité
justement parce que certains disent que
que ce touriste le finalement ne
rapporte pas autant qu'on voudrait le
faire croire dans nos îles je sais pas
qui est c'est certain mais en effet il
ya plusieurs études qui montrent que les
bois tombés touristiques pourraient être
mieux exploité avec des objectifs
beaucoup plus fort à la fente et âme de
nombre de touristes mais c'est peut-être
pas
ce qui compte c'est dit capello se
toiser les indicateurs sont pourtant au
vert fréquentation touristique en hausse
malheureusement l'ouragan maria sur
saint martin et sur saint barthélemy va
nous ramener une centaine d'escales
supplémentaires le malheur des uns
faisant le bonheur des autres
la fréquentation touristique la
scrutation à l'aéroport c'est en
progression tout cela les indicateurs
ces indicateurs la sont en effet au vert
et les prévisions sont bonnes mais ce
sur quoi je pense qu'on devrait se
focaliser c'est plutôt les retombées
touristiques
c'est pas la peine d'avoir un million de
touristes qui dépensent 5 euros vaut
mieux avoir moins semer qui dépensent
beaucoup plus le tourisme de croisière
c'est une dépense de 100 euros en
moyenne contre 60 il ya huit ans c'est
une évolution mais par rapport aux ados
trois îles de la caraïbe on est bien en
deçà de ce qu'on pourrait attendre donc
est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour le
tourisme de croisière spécifiquement par
exemple je pense que pour le tourisme de
croisière spécifiquement là toute la
difficulté c'est que les bateaux de
croisières sont à la fois des amis et
des concurrents c'est à dire que abord
les voyageurs trouve de tout et donc ils
ne sont pas nécessairement tenté de
descendre
donc il faut avoir des excursions et des
activités proposées qui soit tellement
intéressante que les personnes soient
tentés de décembre des sites à visiter
qui soit tellement intéressant que les
personnes soient tentés souhaite
véhiculer portes ouvertes que vous
défoncer le tout le monde le sait ça
j'ai envie de dire si tout le monde le
sait pourquoi ce n'est pas appliquée que
la fota qui encore une fois ce sont des
politiques par exemple qui en veut qui
ont la main sur ce qui doit être fait
devrait organiser cela je pense que les
politiques doivent donner un cadre
peut-être mais finalement ce sont des
opérationnels qu'il faut des personnes
qui sont exécutante qui doivent mettre
en place des actions pour ça avec une
vraie feuille de route c'est à dire
voilà l'objectif
voilà telle action voilà les moyens
qu'on va se donner et voilà comment on
va suivre la mise en place donc avec de
vrais une un vrai suivi des résultats ce
n'est pas le cas je pense qu'aujourd'hui
non ça fait mal ce que vous venez de
dire la messe et c'est comme ça c'est on
n'est pas là pour aujourd'hui on a du
mal à suivre de manière chiffrée de
manière régulière ce qui se passe dans
le tourisme le cnt a fait un effort en
communiquant ces statistiques de manière
plus régulière
c'est aussi le cas de l'aéroport mais je
serai c'est aujourd'hui difficile de
pouvoir se dire ou es ce que la
martinique veux être et va être en
matière de tourisme dans trois ans dans
cinq ans ou dans dix ans que la
martinique vient de faire savoir au
monde à l'occasion de du salon top resa
lamartine vient de faire savoir qu'elle
nous aime qu'elle aime ses visiteurs
avec notamment ce film de lucien jean
baptiste le réalisateur martiniquais
c'est suffisant pour pour donner une
autre image de notre pays
non un vie une vidéo de promotion ne
fait pas tout d'une part parce que c'est
un outil marketing
c'est un outil marketing marketing qui
peut être puissant l'on peut pas se
reposer que sur ça vous avez vu ce film
oui je l ai vu le très bien mais il est
bien il montre la femme couchée il
montre les yoles il montre une famille
je pense que l'idée globale c'était de
montrer toute la chaleur de la
martinique
au delà des paysages se te file qui
selon vous identifie clairement la
martinique est-ce qu'ils identifient
pour un martiniquais
oui parce qu'on se reconnaît on s'est
dit ça c'est la femme couchée et c est
ce qu ils identifient pour quelqu'un qui
n'est jamais venue en martinique ça je
ne sais pas faudrait il faudrait faire
le test
parlons de cette économie tellement
fragile que représente le tourisme on
l'a vu avec saint martin et saint
barthélemy est ce que vous pensez que
dans ce secteur du tourisme on sait être
prévoyants est-ce qu'on saurait par
exemple relevé la tête assez vite si
jamais nous sommes frappés par une
catastrophe naturelle n'ont fait que les
ratios le sujet je pense qu'aujourd'hui
ni les professionnels du tourisme ni les
professionnels tout courant ni même les
maintenir en tant que citoyenne et serra
on n'est pas prêt en cas de catastrophe
naturelle certes les phénomènes qu'on
aille récemment était difficilement on
les avait jamais vus avant mais ils
n'étaient pas même anticipable et du
coup on n'est pas prêt parce que on ne
participe pas aux exercices de
prévention on est on rechigne à ça on ne
communique pas tellement sur le fait
qu'on soit sur une zone qu'ils soient
considérés comme à risque et l'idée
n'est pas de créer un climat anxiogène
vis-à-vis des touristes mais plutôt de
leur dire voilà on est dans une zone à
risques c'est assumé l'échelle pour ce
que l'égypte la tunisie communiquent par
exemple sur le fait qu'ils sont des
zones où j'ai un risque d'attentats
certainement
c'est en tout cas les ambassades
communiqué communique dessus donc nous
il faut assumer
oui on est dans une zone à risque et
voilà les actions préventives qu'on peut
mettre mais tout le monde doit jouer les
vieux cons
des exercices de prévention et que à oui
mais non c'est pas la peine qu'on ya des
alertes et puis oui mais on continue à
rouler etc
on n'est pas prêt on n'est pas prêt et
un jour je pense que ça risque de se
retourner contre nous lorsqu'on vous dit
qu'on n'est pas prêt est ce que c'est la
formation à ce secteur du tourisme que
vous prêtez du doigt alors la formation
en tourisme aujourd'hui en martinique
elle a des failles il ya un plan qui a
été lancé pour pour compenser ça à mon
avis à plusieurs soucis le premier c'est
que c'est au niveau de la motivation des
élèves les élèves vont en tourisme sans
savoir la réalité du métier de talia les
gens se veulent mais moi je peux avoir
rencontré des élèves qui sont par
exemple en bts tourisme à bellevue on
les sentait très motivés par ce secteur
qui semble ouvrir qui semble ouvrir les
bras parce qu'elles ont fait des styles
la plupart de ces et le sport le stage
oui oui mais alors une fois que il ya la
théorie et puis à la réalité les camps
les élèves découvrent découvre les
contraintes du métier
elles sont toujours surprise les élèves
ne connaissent surpris ou de manière
générale les élèves ne connaissent pas
nécessairement non plus la diversité des
métiers ce qui manque aussi en formation
je pense c'est qu'on ne prépare pas
aujourd'hui les générations futures a
exercé le tourisme de demain
c'est une souris sme qui sera beaucoup
plus numérique swizz qui sera beaucoup
plus internationale on les forme encore
comme si on était dans le tourisme des
années 80 2000 à être gentil à sourire
mais ça c'est du comportement de base
j'ai envie de dire dans vite séduit
c'est du basique et si on ne va pas plus
loin c'est un peu dommage comment vous
expliquer aujourd'hui que nos élèves en
bts tourisme lancé à pexiora participe
par exemple très peu aux compétitions
d'élèves au challenge étudiants
nationaux ou internationaux qui sont
restés dans une formation doubiste des
années 70 jouer c'est à dire combien de
petits le petit bois grâce à l'argent
que les comptes spéciaux tout ans a dit
que le tourisme ne se réduit kck sourire
aux gens mais aujourd'hui une diversité
de métiers dans la tourisme est ce que
c'est travailler quand même d'accord
pour dire que nous avons fait beaucoup
d'efforts en terme d'accueil mais ça
c'est sûr et certain on a fait des
efforts en germe on a fait des efforts
en termes d'accueil mais il n'en demeure
pas moins que la formation est
aujourd'hui limite est à dire qu après
un bts tourisme par exemple ou est-ce
que les excuses et les mêmes font ils
sont obligés de partir bien souvent s
ils vont et viennent
il faut pourtant aller chercher le
tourisme de niche c'est ça la solution
pour demain
c'est une des solutions à mon sens parce
que c'est un tourisme con con qui
jusqu'à présent sous-exploité le
tourisme sportif le tourisme de
gastronomie le chile tourisme le
tourisme et d'architecturé on est quand
même l'acteur d'aimé césaire il suffit
pas juste de s'en revendiquer il suffit
de il faut aussi valoriser ça on est la
terre d'edouard glissant et dans le
monde entier
il ya des personnes qui connaissent a
donc pour moi on a du potentiel mais on
met pas en place les actions pour le
pôle est maximisée voilà qui devrait
alimenter les alimentations les laisse
alimentation mais les conversations au
cours des prochains jours merci d'avoir
avec nous
madeline king on rappelle que vous êtes
directrice de l'agencé marjorie qui
édite entre autres veille tourisme
antique bien connu sur les réseaux
sociaux merci bonne journée
merci avant
[Musique]